بقيت سيمبرتف همم توسان اولدنري
[موسيقى]
اوروبا اوروبا
بشكل مباشر نتحدث عن دول البطيخ نتحدث عن
رومانيا نتحدث عن هولندا
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا بمنظومات الدفاع الجوي يجب ان
يكون اسرع من هجمات روسيا الصاروخيه
القادمه تزويدنا بالدبابات الغربيه يجب ان
يكون اسرع من اي هجوم روسي جديد
[موسيقى]
نعلم انها بحاجه الى دبابات وهناك مشاورات
مع المانيا قلنا ان لدينا في مخزوناتنا
دبابات ليبارت اثنان وطبعا المانيا
وبولندا ستقدمان اعدادا اكبر لكن يمكن ان
نساعد نحن ايضا من خلال الصيانه والتدريب
على الدبابات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انطلاقا من النتيجه النهائيه والنصر
الحتميه هناك امور قائمه تشكل جزءا لا
يتجزا من مصرنا ومنها وحده وتماسك شحن
الروسي بتعدد من هذه الامور شجاعه وبطوله
المقاتلين
[موسيقى]
معنى العسكري
وبالامكانيات وبال دراسه الارض وطبيعه
الارض المرحله القادمه هي المرحله
الاساسيه والوحيده قد تكون في زفروجا